>> Tucker: AT BEST.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
WHY IS ALL OF THIS
HAPPENINGS?
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TOLD YOU
FOR THE LAST MONTH THERE'S
ONE REAL REASON AT THE
BOTTOM, NOBODY IS ABOVE THE
LAW.
NOW, THERE ARE CAVEATS TO
THAT OF COURSE, NO ONE IS
ABOVE THE LAW EXCEPT FOR
ANYONE WHO MIGHT POTENTIALLY
VOTE DEMOCRAT IN WHICH CASE
LAWS ARE RACIST AND MUST BE
IGNORED.
YOU KNOW THAT.
THAT'S PRETTY AMUSING.
HERE IS SOMETHING EVEN
FUNNIER.
THOSE ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT THAT WE JUST SAW
PASSED IN ORDER TO UPHOLD
THE LAW THAT NOBODY IS
ABOVE, WELL NEITHER ARTICLE
THAT APPARENTLY HAVE JUST
BEEN PASSED ACTUALLY ACCUSES
THE PRESIDENT OF BREAKING A
SPECIFIC LAW.
HUH?
SO WHY ARE WE HERE?
WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
THIS?
WHY HAVE WE DEVOTED 43
MINUTES SO FAR TONIGHT TO
THIS TOPIC?
WHY IS THE PRESIDENT BEING
IMPEACHED ASK HAKEEM
JEFFRIES.
IMPEACHMENT HAS A LOT TO DO
WITH, YOU NEVER WOULD HAVE
GUESSED THIS BY THE WAY, HAS
A LOT TO DO WITH SLAVERY.
I BET YOU DIDN'T SEE THAT
COMING.
WATCH HAKEEM JEFFRIES
EXPLAIN.
>> THERE ARE SOME WHO
CYNICALLY ARGUE THAT THE
IMPEACHMENT OF THIS
PRESIDENT WILL FURTHER
DIVIDE AN ALREADY FRACTURED
UNION.
BUT THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN DIVISION AND
CLARIFICATION.
SLAVERY ONCE DIVIDED THE
NATION BUT EMANCIPATORS ROSE
UP TO CLARIFY THAT ALL MEN
ARE CREATED EQUALLY.
SUFFRAGE ONCE DIVIDED THE
NATION BUT WOMEN ROSE UP TO
CLARIFY THAT ALL VOICES MUST
BE HEARD IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN DIVISION AND
CLARIFICATION.
>> Tucker: HUH?
DID YOU HEAR THAT?
DID YOU UNDERSTAND IT?
NO.
BECAUSE IT WAS INSIRVEL
BECAUSE IT WAS DUMB
INCAUSE IT WAS DUMB
INCIUSE IT WAS DUMB
INCIPHE IT WAS DUMB
INCIPHERIT WAS DUMB
INCIPHERAB WAS DUMB
INCIPHERABLEAS DUMB
INCIPHERABLE.S DUMB
INCIPHERABLE.ONDUMB
INCIPHERABLE.ON SMB
INCIPHERABLE.ON SOSH FARCES BROG
INCIPHERABLE.ON SOSH FARCES BROT
INCIPHERABLE.ON SOSH FARCES BROO
YOU.
BEGINNING WITH RUSSIA AND
STORMY DANIELS AND
IMPEACHMENT.
IF YOU ARE A CYNICAL PERSON
YOU MIGHT SUSPECT ALL OF
THIS WAS DESIGNED FROM THE
BEGINNING TO DISTRACT YOU
FROM WHAT'S ACTUALLY GOING
ON.
AND WHAT IS ACTUALLY GOING
ON?
WELL, A LOT IS GOING ON.
AROUND THE WORLD AND IN THIS
COUNTRY.
FOR EXAMPLE, ONE AMONG MANY,
BEFORE IT LEAVES TOWN FOR
CHRISTMAS, THE CONGRESS WILL
PASS A 2,000 PAGE SPENDING
BILL THAT DANA JUST
REFERRED.
TO SAY IT AMOUNTS TO
$1.4 TRILLION.
WHAT'S IN THAT BILL?
WOULDN'T YOU LIKE TO KNOW?
YOU WERE TOO BUSY WATCHING
IMPEACHMENT TO FIND OUT.
WE TOOK A LITTLE TIME AND
CHECKED.
HERE'S A SELECTION.
FOR EXAMPLE, THOUSANDS OF
LIBERIANS FROM LIBERIA
LIVING IN THIS COUNTRY WILL
GET A SPECIAL PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP.
WHY?
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
DON'T ASK.
IT WAS NEVER DEBATED.
YOU HAD NO IDEA IT WAS
EVENING HAPPENING.
THIS IS YOUR COUNTRY.
YOU DIDN'T KNOW AND OF
COURSE THAT WAS THE POINT.
WHAT ABOUT THE WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN GOING ON NOW FOR
18 YEARS?
A FEW WEEKS AGO THE POST SAY
OUR LEADERS HAVE BEEN
SYSTEMATICALLY LYING TO US
HOW THE WAR IS FAILING AND
HAS BEEN FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
THE SCANDAL OF THE YEAR.
INSTEAD THOSE DOCUMENTS ARE
FORGOTTEN, ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY.
WHY?
THANKS TO IMPEACHMENT.
IN FACT, IN THIS NEW
SPENDING BILL CONGRESS JUST
VOTED TO KEEP THE MONEY
FLOWING UNIMPEDED TO THAT
FAILED WAR.
$4 BILLION WILL GO TO THE
AFGHAN SECURITY FORCES,
REALLY?
IT'S LIKE A JOKE.
WE KNOW FOR DEAD CERTAIN
THAT MONEY WILL BE WASTED
THE SECOND IT GETS THERE THE
TROOPS WE HIRE WILL DESSERT.
THEIR WEAPONS WILL WIND UP
WITH THE TALIBAN.
IF ANYTHING THE MONEY THAT
WE SEND IS MORE LIKELY BE
SPENT KILLING AMERICAN
FORCES THAN TURNING
AFGHANISTAN INTO BELGIUM OR
WHATEVER THE MISSION IS WE
HAVE NO IDEA.
BUT WE KNOW IT'S NOT GOING
TO ACHIEVE THAT BUT CONGRESS
IS DOING IT ANYWAY.
MEANWHILE, CONGRESS IS, IN
ADDITION TO ALL OF THAT,
STILL BUSILY WORKING TO
UNDERMINE YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
THE SPENDING BILL CURRENTLY
INCLUDES $25 MILLION TO
SPEND ON, QUOTE:  GUN
VIOLENCE RESEARCH.
DON'T LIE TO YOURSELF.
THAT'S NOT SOCIAL SCIENCE.
IT'S MONEY THAT WILL GO TO
IDEOLOGICALLY MOTIVATED
RESEARCH WITH ONLY ONE
PURPOSE.
GIVING A PRETEXT TO BREWER
DEMOCRATS TO REDUCE YOUR
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
YOU THINK THAT MIGHT BOTHER
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE, AS YOU
KNOW, THEY SPENT ALL WEEK
EXTOLLING THE CONSTITUTION,
HOW MUCH THEY CARE ABOUT IT,
HOW THEY ARE REPRESENTING
THE FRAMERS.
BUT OF COURSE THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT THE BILL OF
RIGHTS.
T. IF IT'S AN OBSTACLE TO
THEIR POWER, THEY ARE
AGAINST IT.
THAT CATEGORY INCLUDES BOTH
STUBBORN CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS LIKE THE FIRST
AND SECOND AND SITTING
PRESIDENT.
CONGRESSMAN AL GREEN BY THE
WAY BASICALLY SAID SO TODAY
AHEAD OF CONGRESS.
JUST A FEW MINUTES AGO
IMPEACHING THE PRESIDENT ON
BOTH ARTICLES ONE AND TWO.
WHEN GREEN CALLED FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S IMPEACHMENT, HE
AT ANY TIME MENTION HIGH
CRIMES
DIIMES
DIDNES
DIDN'T MENTION HIGH CRIMES
AND MISDEMEANORS.
HE ACCUSED THE PRESIDENT OF
DISAGREEING WITH HIS VIEWS
ON IMMIGRATION.
WATCH THIS.
>> IN THE NAME OF DEMOCRACY,
ON BEHALF OF THE REPUBLIC,
AND FOR THE SAKE OF THE MANY
WHO ARE SUFFERING, I WILL
VOTE TO IMPEACH AND I
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
DO SO AS WELL.
>> Tucker: WHAT DID THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH ARTICLES 1
AND 2?
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH IMPEACHMENT?
IF YOU ARE CONFUSED, YOU
DON'T KNOW HOW IT WORKS.
SO, HERE'S A PRIMMER, HERE'S
ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW.
WHEN YOU OPPOSE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
IMMIGRATION PLANS, WHAT YOU